-Let's get to the news.
Tonight was the second part of
the second Democratic debate
and it was fine, I guess,
but it did kind of feel like
when your fun aunt goes home
and you're left
with your boring family again.
[ Laughter ]
Aww. Aunt Marianne lets us
finger-paint on the wall!
[ Laughter ]
Entrepreneur Andrew Yang use
his opening statement tonigh
to differentiate himself
from President Trump, saying
"The opposite of Donald Trum
is an Asian man who likes math."
[ Laughter ]
Which is a great point, but
actually think the opposit
of Trump would be a black gu
who is a good president.
There you go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Didn't know where you guys wer
gonna land on that one.
[ Laughter ]
According to a debate coac
on CNN,
Senator Bernie Sanders
got a B-plus
for his performance last night
which he was
perfectly happy with.
"The last thing I want is fo
my grade to be in the top 1%!"
[ Laughter ]
B-plus.
[ Applause ]
According to the final numbers
author Marianne Williamson was
the most searched-for candidat
after last night's debate,
which is silly.
You don't search for
Marianne Williamson.
You just leave a window open
and put a thimble full of
CBD oil on the sill.
[ Laughter ]
The personal Wikipedia page fo
presidential hopeful
John Delaney was vandalize
last night to say that
Senator Elizabeth Warren
killed him
during the Democratic debate
it's now been corrected
to reflect
that he is in serious
but stable condition.
[ Laughter ]
The White House has announce
that next week President Trump
will visit a central Florida
retirement community,
or as he told Wilbur Ross,
"Let's go for a little drive."
[ Laughter ]
"Look at all these nice friend
for you, Wilbur."
[ Laughter ]
"Shuffleboard,
you like shuffleboard.
Don't cry, Wilbur."
[ Laughter ]
A Delta pilot was removed
from a fully boarded fligh
and arrested yesterday
for allegedly
attempting to fly the plan
while intoxicated.
How did he get alcohol,
said people in coach.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Finally, a Florida man who goe
by the nickname "Murder"
and has the word
"murder" tattooed on his nec
pleaded guilty yesterday
to murder.
[ Laughter ]
Well, at least no one will hav
to ask him what he's in for.